de gaulle pompidou mitterrand chirac
giscard d'estaing cinq présidents et un
point commun lequel ils ont tous eu un
timbre à leur effigie à chaque président
qui décède et un thème qui est mis en
profite pour la collection
il ya une tradition à la poste celle
d'éditer des timbres un an après la mort
d'un président en 1970 décès du général
de gaulle un an plus tard il n'a pas
droit à un timbre mais quatre chacun
d'entre eux représentent différentes
étapes de sa carrière politique pour
répondre aux voeux du public et pour
honorer la mémoire du général de gaulle
l'administration postale française a
émis aujourd'hui même date anniversaire
de sa mort une bande de quatre timbres
consacrés aux premiers résistants de
france
après de gaulle georges pompidou
1974 le président vient de mourir des
pays étrangers notamment d'anciennes
colonies françaises lui rendent hommage
avec un timbre une initiative saluée
dans l'émission télé philatélie et le
voyons ici aux côtés du président
camerounais ahmadou ahidjo et du
président albert bernard bongo lors de
sa visite au gabon également avec le
président hamani diori lors du voyage de
janvier 1972 au niger un an plus tard en
1975 la poste française sans encombre à
l'éffigie de l'ancien président c'est
dans le cantal mais aussi à paris à la
maison de la poste et de la philatélie
que vous pourrez vous procurer le 2
avril en vente premier jour le timbre à
l'effigié du président georges pompidou
qui sera dès le lendemain mise en vente
générale dans tous les bureaux de poste
de france
après pompidou il faut attendre 1997
pour qu'un autre président ait droit à
son timbre
françois mitterrand décédé un an plus
tôt sur le timbre une photo officielle
prise en 1982 prix 3 francs il est vendu
en avant-première à la poste du louvre
mais il n'a pas tellement de succès un
petit peu déçu beaucoup de monde au
louvre quelques personnes quelques
touristes viennent à celle et ans
très en revanche 23 ans plus tard en
2020 c'est la cohue pour jacques chirac
un timbre tirée à 500 mille exemplaires
en corrèze au musée jacques chirac
philatélistes ou non ils veulent tous
savoir leur timbre tulle ac pur plaisir
de venir pour avoir le cachet premier
jour dernier président sur un timbre
valéry giscard d'estaing un timbre
sortie à l'occasion du premier
anniversaire de sa mort en 2021
[Musique]